so Donald Trump went to Singapore to
negotiate with North Korea's Kim jong-un
Kim made the same vague promises that
prior North Korean leaders had made and
not held up their end of the bargain
with regard to the agreements that are
reached Donald Trump called it a victory
bragged about the nuclear threat is over
bragged about this massive deal than he
made and then of course nothing happened
and nobody heard from North Korea for 10
or 14 days none of the remains of
American soldiers were returned which
was maybe the one notable element of the
agreement that had been made but we were
told that any second the progress will
happen because Trump's Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo is going to go to
North Korea he's gonna get it done get
some results and start bringing home
those remains of US US soldiers
well Pompeo went and kim jong-un blew
off the scheduled one-on-one meeting
with the trump Secretary of State and
went to a rural potato farm instead to
speak inspirationally to North Korean
potato farmers
you couldn't possibly create a more
condescending and ridiculous way to show
your complete lack of concern for your
relationship with the United States then
bailing on a one-on-one meeting with the
Secretary of State to go to a place
where they grow potatoes to chat with
farmers and Pompeyo was there he was
supposed to have this meeting he was in
Pyongyang right after the supposedly
historic deal which represented newfound
willingness and inspirational dedication
from Kim jong-un to fixing the problems
of the relationship with the United
States Kim Jong who never showed up they
sent a deputy of his instead to meet
with Pompeo and we now have pictures of
Kim jong-un in this rural area dressed
in his I don't know what you call those
his best whites his bleached whites
providing guidance to potato farmers
clearly the actions of a guy very eager
to deal with the United States right
what guidance can he even offer to
potato farmers that's what I'm wondering
he knows about everything he knows about
golfing he knows about nuclear energy he
knows about potato farming I think that
his father was known to be proficient in
animal husbandry as well Ebola 300 every
time - kim jeong-hoon
either that or holds holes-in-one the
first time he played golf or he was
making fluent Korean at one year of age
or something like who knows in the
meantime Pompey owes meetings with
whoever was left to meet with him were a
total disaster after the meetings North
Korea referred to them as regrettable
and filled with gangster-like demands
from Pompeo could this trip have gone
any worse and a source close to these
this trip by Pompeo said that quote the
North Koreans were just messing around
not serious about moving forward which
is what every reasonable person has said
from the beginning every reasonable
person has said they're not serious
there's simply not serious about moving
forward on this yeah you could have
anticipated this but maybe Pompeo and
Trump thought that a new page had been
turned yes I new leaf turned over a new
leaf I think that sounds a little bit
naive though don't you think it sounds
more than a little bit naive and there's
a senior fellow and director of the
defense posture project at the
Federation of American scientists
so quite a mouthful his name is Adam
mount he says this is a dead end like
this is just this is going nowhere it's
over and even the mere idea that this is
going to proceed as Donald Trump
reported to us that it would is a
laughable joke at this time could we
even invent a way that this could have
gone any worse
like could could is there anything Kim
jong-un could have done during this
visit by Pompeo that would have been
worse than bailing on the meeting and
going to a potato farm maybe if he
brought Pompeo to the potato farm with
him and had him start working the fields
that that's I think that that is one of
the few ways that this could have
actually been worse send me your
thoughts if anybody still thinks this is
going somewhere please let me know this
episode is sponsored in part by better
help calm slash Pakman which gives you
access to a fully licensed and
experienced psychologist or therapist
through videophone and text I know from
the emails I get that in our audience
like in the broader world there are
people who are struggling with different
issues in their lives and many of them
choose not to talk to somebody about it
either for financial reasons for reasons
of stigma associated with seeking out a
therapist and I think it's really
important to do everything you can to
get past that
because it's really important to talk to
someone when you feel like that's the
right thing to do
and what better help calm provides is
number one the elimination of the stigma
that could be associated with it you
work through video phone whichever
method is best for you you also will be
able to save money compared to seeing an
in-person therapist and it is so easy to
get started that I encourage you to go
to better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa k/m am